[Musique]
pour soir les enfants
notre ami nounours est très en forme ce
soir il a apporté tout son attirail de
bricoleur de bricoleur mais je ne rigole
pas j'aurais pas patron pardon nounours
c'est vrai tu réparé très bien j'aurai
par tous ceux qui a besoin d'être réparé
eu il ya sûrement beaucoup pas faire
chez mes deux petits amis mon échelle et
europe propose aux sûrement dans une
maison il y a toujours quelque chose a
cassé
postroff du color bonsoir
qu'est-ce que 2,5 des outils les enfants
j'aurais pas voilà mon bateau non papa
et mari paris l'électricité natis n'est
pas l'électricité
c'est autre chose dans une maison il ya
toujours quelque chose de cassé mais non
êtes vous sûr que tout marche bien dans
la salle de bain ouais alors très bien
bon la table elle a l'air solide
[Musique]
roubaix cette fenêtre s'ouvre toute
seule elle ne ferme pas oh j'ai bien
fait d'apporter des outils aux je me
demande ce que vous auriez fait sans moi
alors un petit marteau un peu importe où
tu devrais te frapper plus fort injuste
le puzzle portons au doigt ou le lot
parce que des femmes oui je me suis fait
mal
amap à tous pour vos petites annonces
mais ça va passer ou monde bouche de
peut-être hausse mais non la vie du
coucher ça te fera du bien
tu es drôle en direct et juste au pouce
c'est vrai nom s'il faut pas juger deux
pouces et vilain méchant tu te bats lama
pas tout
ouah allons garder mon auto
je devrai encore vous faire des
réparations au ma parole
ne te fâche pas ne mange on dit
seulement que ce temps bien avoir leur
tâche et s'est sans pause oui eh bien
moi je vous dis oui aux vitesses et
bonne nuit les enfants
banier mais ne met nuit nicolas suis pas
ta bouche tu sais pas te poses pas
preneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà notre grand bricoleur il ma
parole
tu suces ton pouce mais nous aurons nous
patrons c'est pas celui de sucer son
pouce c'est parce que je me suis fait un
petit bobo que ce presque flippant
tant mieux car il ne faut pas sucer son
pouce
même avant de s'endormir n'est ce pas
les enfants howe il pas trop bonne nuit
allez vous coucher bien sagement et
faites de beaux rêves à dolbeau
[Musique]